bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à strasbourg pour
cette édition deraedt et aux nouvelles
émissions et nouveau décor oui katia et
dans cette émission nous irons à paimpol
en bretagne une ville qui testent un
champ d'hydroliennes une machine qui
permet de produire de l'électricité
grâce aux courants marins
mais d'abord l'actualité les dirigeants
européens sont tombés d'accord pour
faire l'union bancaire mais alors est ce
que les banquiers compte plus que les
citoyens c'est la question impertinente
de la semaine c'était mal parti en trang
et la merkel et françois hollande en
désaccord sur le sujet numéro un
à l'ordre du jour du dernier sommet
européen l'union bancaire
paris veut aller vite faire la réforme
avant la fin de l'année mais pour berlin
cela revient à foncer dans le mur
le président et la chancelière finissent
de s'expliquer dans les couloirs et
quelques heures plus tard surprise ils
tombent d'accord
l'union bancaire se fera plus tôt que
prévu comme le souhaitait la france elle
se mettra en oeuvre à partir du 1er
janvier dès lors que le cadre législatif
aura été adopté mais l'allemagne a posé
ses conditions
notre ministère des finances travaille
sur ce dossier mais nous voulons réussir
quelque chose de solide donc l'union
bancaire ne se mettra pas en place avant
la fin de l'année 2013
une fois le système en place toutes les
banques de la zone euro sans exception
seront placées sous l'égide d'un
surveillant unique la banque centrale
européenne qui sera assistée des dix
sept banques centrales de la zone euro
personne ne pourra plus dissimulé de
bombe cachée dans son bilan sans que big
brother ne soit au courant est désormais
si une banque un problème elle pourra
demander l'aide directe du mécanisme
européen de stabilité sans que les états
donc les contribuables mettent la main à
la poche
il aura donc fallu trois ans de travail
de discussions de négociations pour
tenter d'assainir le système bancaire
européen
mais les citoyens ont l'impression que
les dirigeants portent moins d'attention
à leurs problèmes qu'ils sont moins
mobilisés quand il s'agit de sauver le
programme erasmus ou bien l'aide
alimentaire aux plus pauvres alors les
banquiers sont ils plus que les citoyens
voient là et nous sommes revenus à
strasbourg un député nous a rejoint jean
paul gauzès bonjour bonjour vous êtes
membre de la commission des affaires
économiques ici au parlement européen et
vous siéger au sein du groupe ppe qui
rassemble les partis de droite et de
centre-droit en europe
alors je vous ai vu réagir pendant ce
sujet vous connaissez bien là le monde
de la banque puisque vous y aviez même
travaillé il ya quelques années
est ce que pour vous on en a pas un peu
trop fait pour les banquiers on a vu que
depuis 2008 il ya eu beaucoup de
gouvernements qui ont volé au secours de
banques mal en point aujourd'hui on met
en place une union bancaire est ce que
ça va se faire au détriment du citoyen
au scrs n'a rien à voir non ça ne sera
pas au détriment de citoyens c'est au
contraire pour rassurer et pour donner
de la solidité au aussi seulement de
terre le système bancaire est important
alors il ya des déviations il ya eu des
spéculations abusive
il ya eu beaucoup d'erreurs qui ont été
faites mais le système dans lequel est
important parce que c'est lui qui
fournit l'énergie dont a besoin
l'économie pour fonctionner est ce
l'objectif
finalement c'est premièrement de faire
en sorte que les halles finances soit au
service de l'économie réelle et
deuxièmement qu'elle ne se laisse pas
aller à des pratiques qui ont été tout à
fait dommageable est-ce que typiquement
ça va permettre le fait de confier à une
autorité unique la banque centrale
européenne le contrôle des banques est
ce que ça va permettre d'éviter demain
des affaires du type affaire kerviel
oui et non l'objectif évidemment c'est
d'assurer un contrôle surtout un
contrôle qui soit plus impartial comme
contrôle national c'est pour ça qu'il ya
une supervision belge signale que le
parlement l'avait demandée en 2010 et
que nous avions donné toute l'
architecture possible à l'époque les
états membres n'ont pas voulu sans
réfléchir maintenant ils reviennent bien
sûr parce qu'on les y ait trois ans vous
l'ayez trois ans et c'était appréciable
mais
des affaires comme kerviel pourront
toujours arriver c'est comme quand
j'étais avocat me disais mais pourquoi
on n'interdit pas le vol le vol est
réprimée mais il n'est pas interdit
on peut toujours on peut toujours aller
contrôler de façon de très fines
mais pour ça il faut beaucoup de monde
et c'est coûteux et deuxièmement quand
comme dans le cartère vielle vous avez
défauts qui sont faits c'est à dire que
ont fait une main une manoeuvre
d'escroquerie à ce moment là la
perception de l'escroquerie est
difficile dans un système compliqué faut
un certain temps pour s'en apercevoir
alors vous dites que les banques ça
aussi pour fonction de prêter de
l'argent à ceux qui en ont besoin et
notamment les jeunes entrepreneurs les
patrons de petites et moyennes
entreprises
est ce que demain avec ce système met en
place d'une union bancaire les banques
seront plus enclins plus généreuse
prêteront plus facilement de l'argent à
ces à ces acteurs économiques qui ont la
supervision ne devrait pas avoir d'effet
particulier sur sa en revanche les
règles qui sont en préparation sur
l'appel crd4 c'est à dire les besoins en
fonds propres des banques
sas être sont de nature c'est compliqué
mais c'est de nature à limiter la
possibilité de crédit sallie à partir du
moment où on veut plus de sécurité moins
de risques dans les banques
évidemment on est on empêche l'effet
multiplicateur et donc il n'est pas
impossible que les crédits deviennent
moins disponibles qu'il n'était si on
met une réglementation transfère le
problème c'est l' équilibre entre la
sécurité le risque et l'aide à
l'économie
je crois que ce qui faut améliorer c'est
la mesure du risque mesuré l du risque
s'est pas passion de vendre des crédits
konya droit c'est parce qu'on fait des
activités qui sont bien encadrés
mais dont le risque est maîtrisé qu'on
peut obtenir des crédits avec l'union
bancaire désormais n'est les états
c'est-à-dire les contribuables ne
interviendront pas directement au
secours d'une banque si elles mêmes
alors est ce que c'est ça n'est pas
directement l'effet de l'union bancaire
non plus vous c est compliqué mais
c'était une condition que l'allemagne
accepte que le fonds de secours européen
puisse intervenir parce que parce que
s'il y avait un contrôle sur une
supervision européenne elle sera mieux
fait et -10 questionnaire que si elle
est faite au niveau national bien que
par exemple en france le contrôle des
membres se fait d'une façon tout à fait
efficace mais c'est pas forcément le cas
dans tous les pays
paul par exemple les allemands ne
voudrais vous ne voulez pas mais il
change de point de vue contrôleur caisse
epargne
mais il voulait contrôler les caisses
d'épargné espagnoles c'est un peu
contradictoire tout à fait
contradictoires mais c'est un des
aspects aussi l'europe mais le
cette ses meilleurs contrats pour les
contribuables ont posé la question des
contribuables les bons contrôles
permettent d'éviter les erreurs ou les
où les difficultés mais le deuxième
aspect de ce mécanisme d'inclusion
bancaire ce sera la mise en place d'un
système de résolution des crises des
banques avec par les banques elles-mêmes
c'est à dire la création d'un fonds qui
permettra au cas où une banque aurait
des difficultés pour s'adresser à soho
pour
remettre les choses au point et non plus
haut au trésor public c'est à dire comme
le disait il ya quelques mois le
commissaire européen michel barnier
désormais s'il ya un problème les
banques paieront pour les banques les
états les banques paieront pour les
banques la condition de problèmes soient
photographes c'est à dire que le fonds
qui sera une assurance en quelque sorte
et les moyens nécessaires pour faire
face à chris c'est vrai que c'est pour
ça qu'il faut arriver un système
supervision efficace au niveau européen
parce que si toutes les banques avaient
une crise a même moment bien là le fond
aussi grand soit-il ne permettrait pas
de régler la question
donc il faut éviter la reproduction de
risque systémique c'est à dire du
système bancaire comme on l'a vu dans
les années qui viennent de s'écouler
alors ya un risque est toujours présent
en europe en espagne la banque bank ya
est très mal emploi est très mal en
point
d'ailleurs c'est un sujet central de
préoccupation du gouvernement espagnol
mais typiquement 7,7 cette union
bancaire ne va pas être utile pour
l'espagne que se passera-t-il si
l'espagne a besoin de cet argent même
maintenant si les spurs cet argent
maintenant normalement le ms ne pourra
pas fonctionner puisque les allemands
ont fait une condition de la supervision
européenne de la mise en jeu de ces
sommes
il faudra bien trouver d'autres
solutions mais s'ils voulaient l'exemple
espagnol montre à la fois montrent les
limites supervision nationales
lorsqu'il ya eu des tests en espagne les
tests ont été plutôt positifs et puis
tout d'un coup on s'aperçoit que c'était
pas la réalité
donc c'est pour ça que les allemands
notamment ont voulu cette union bancaire
on en reparlera très prochainement avec
vous merci beaucoup jean paul gauzès
d'avoir été sur europe hebdo alors on va
parler d'un autre sujet on va parler de
david cameron qui a ouvert les
hostilités sur le budget européen il a
dit qu'il mettrait son veto en cas
d'augmentation des ressources
déclarations tonitruantes alors que dans
les rues de londres les cris se faisait
plus fort pour dénoncer la politique
d'austérité c'est à la une de notre
zapping européen regarder
ma position est très simple répond pas
un accord satisfaisant sur le budget
européen
si mes partenaires soit des
augmentations massives de décence je
l'évoquais le premier ministre
britannique david cameron a donné des
gages à sa majorité conservatrice il
refusera toute dérive du budget européen
il souhaite de budget séparé l'un pour
les 17 pays de la zone euro et le second
pour les dix autres dont le royaume uni
mon chiffre du jour et je crois que 16%
des fonctionnaires européens gagnent
plus de 120 euros par an eh bien au
royaume uni au contraire nous réduisons
les dépenses des fonctionnaires et de
l'administration centrale
l'austérité ça ne marche pas c'est le
slogan phare de l'imposante
manifestation qui a envahi le centre de
londres ce samedi
ni les syndicats ni la police n'ont
fourni d'estimation mais les
protestataires étaient assurément des
dizaines de milliers je n'accepte pas
cette idée de dire que notre pays serait
un poids pour l'europe
nous sommes au contraire un acteur très
important et incontournable au sein de
l'union
voilà alors nous sommes avec clémentine
forissier bonjour je vous êtes
rédactrice en chef d'oeuvre active point
fr le site d'info numéro un sur les
politiques européennes
alors david cameron
a prévenu si ça ne se passe pas comme il
le souhaite il mettra son veto au budget
européen le budget européen qui n'est
même pas encore en cours de discussion
est ce que c'est pas un peu dur comme
comme position est-ce que c'est lui qui
va donner le ton de la prochaine
discussion budgétaire
les britanniques sont toujours dans
cette position dans les négociations
budgétaires à long terme puisqu'on parle
d'un budget sur sept ans pour la
négociation de l'ue c'est pas étonnant
qu'ils qu'ils le fassent un peu la pluie
et le beau temps ça arrive à chaque fois
ce qui est ce qui est bizarre c'est
cette position très radicale avant même
que le sommet de dons qui a lieu en fin
novembre entre les dirigeants européens
aient commencé et c'est vrai que négoce
est arrivé aux négociations en disant je
dirais non
quoi qu'il arrive étant donné que les
propositions actuellement sur la table
sont plutôt quand même au dessus de ce
qu'ils souhaitent c'est un peu étrange
est ce qu'il est en position de force
notamment face à l'allemagne
un gala merkel qui a prévenu que si les
choses allaient comme ça peut-être que
que certains rendez vous européen serait
seront annulés c'est ce qu'elle a dit
dans le 'financial times' est ce que ça
laisse augurer de discussion vraiment
très tendue on voit déjà que les
britanniques en tout cas en coulisses où
la porte c'est à dire que après
justement la réaction de gala merkel qui
a dit je ne viendrai pas si jamais c'est
pour ne pas discuter je ne viendrai pas
je ne viendrai pas sommet du monde
certains porte parole de cameron ont dit
bon c'est une négociation qui réouvre la
porte donc moi je pense que de toute
façon tout le monde sera là et tout le
monde va se mettre autour de la table
pour discuter
alors précisons que c'est un budget qui
est donc réduit puisqu'il n'y a pas
beaucoup de sous et que certains pays
poussent pour augmenter la pommette plus
d'argent au pot commun c'est celui
d'hier pour pouvoir notamment financé
certaines
certaines politiques la passation de
commande pour qu'on la comprenne bien
c'est qu'il ne veut pas du tout qu'ils
aient la moindre augmentation c'est ça
non il va un gel des dépenses de façon
globale ce qui réduirait en réalité le
budget à long terme de l'union
européenne et ce qui est sa position
elle est vraiment dur par rapport à
celle qui est celle de la commission
européenne et même par rapport à celle
de l'allemagne qui est légèrement en
dessous qui circulent en ce moment il a
même proposé une piste pour réduire les
dépenses couper dans les salaires des
fonctionnaires européens est ce que
c'est du vent ou est-ce que
si vous pensez de cette île est pas le
seul en fait ça sur ce point là tout le
monde est d'accord ça fait des années
que les états essaient de dire à la
commission il faut que vous coupiez dans
les salaires de hauts fonctionnaires
donner l'exemple pour exactement parce
que nous on le fait au plan national
dont il ya pas de raison que vous ne
fassiez pas mais c'est un mécanisme un
peu particulier tout ce qui concerne
notamment les salaires des
fonctionnaires les états s'étaient
engagés par le passé à ce qu'ils soient
indexés sur l'inflation
donc en fait il avait accepté pendant un
certain nombre d'années que les salaires
augmentent régulièrement et donc il ya
eu une bataille qui s'est engagé entre
la commission et les états ça finira par
changer mais pour l'instant disons
cameron n'est pas le seul à faire cette
demande
alors pour l'instant les voix sont un
peu discordante entre la france
l'allemagne la grande-bretagne et scrute
dans ces conditions un terrain d'entente
est possible sur un sujet quand même
important il faut que qu'un terrain
d'entente soit trouvé parce que personne
n'a intérêt à éviter même pas les
britanniques à ce qu'on trouve par
l'accord sur le budget à long terme de
lieu parce que si on trouve pas d'accord
c'est les bus et le budget de l'année
précédente
pour schématiser qui sera utilisé comme
référence pendant les trois prochaines
années et donc en réalité les
britanniques qui veulent par exemple
baisser le budget agricole est augmentée
de la recherche n'obtiendront pas gain
de cause
donc on va trouver une solution comme
toujours en europe merci clémentine
forissier d'avoir été avec nous alors on
va parler justement de certains fonds
européens qui sont utiles qui figure au
budget européen s'écarte du feder le
fonds européen de développement régional
en bretagne il a servi par exemple à
mettre en place un champ d'hydroliennes
on va en parler dans un instant n'aura
hamadi recevra michèle rivasi mais
voyons d'abord à quoi ressemblent ces
énergies reportage de pierre lascars
à quelques centaines de mètres de saint
malo sous cette route on exploite
l'énergie de la mer depuis bientôt 40
ans l'usiné marémotrice de la rance
produit de l'électricité pour plus de
235 mille personnes soit l'équivalent de
la ville de rennes et le principe est on
ne peut plus simple lorsque la mère
arrive à marée haute
on ferme l'ensemble des vannes ce qui
fait que la mère est en prison dans le
bassin une fois que la mer descend et
qu'elle est descendue suffisamment sur
l'usiné marémotrice à peu près 4 m on
ouvre on ouvre les vannes ce qui permet
de halo de passer à travers les turbines
et de produire de l'électricité
problème une usine marémotrice ne peut
être installé que sur un vaste bras de
mer avec d'importants coefficients de
marée des contraintes géographiques qui
ont poussé edf va se tourner vers une
nouvelle technologie l'hydrolien essayé
dans les environs de paimpol toujours en
bretagne que sont testés ces nouvelles
machines le fonctionnement de cette
turbine de 16 mètres de diamètre est
comparable à celui d'un moulin l'hélice
est immergé par 35 mètres de fond et est
mis en mouvement par les courants marins
l'énergie produite par la rotation des
turbines est transformée en électricité
plus acheminé à terre par un câble
jusqu'à un transformateur raccordés au
réseau électrique
le courant est ensuite distribuée aux
particuliers vincent denby wilkes qui
pilote le projet voit dans cette
nouvelle technologie
un gage de fiabilité prometteur au
regard des autres énergies renouvelables
sionnel énergique présente cette grande
caractéristique d'être absolument
prévisible et prévisible des heures et
des années à l'avancé puisque on connaît
des années à l'avance ce qu'est
l'alternance des bars et l'amplitude de
ces marais leur de ces marais et donc on
sera très exactement à quel moment aux
produits ce qui est un avantage
extrêmement importante pour des énergies
renouvelables c'est clair les
caractéristiques du solaire ou de
l'éolien c'est que ce sont des énergies
a terminé intermittente avec une
prédictibilité qui était difficile
implanté de telles machines sous la mer
revient à empiéter sur l'espace de
travail des marins pêcheurs
mais du côté du comité local des pêches
on a douté longtemps accepté le partage
de l'océan tout ce qui appartenait pas
virtuellement pêcheurs il ya 40 ans 50
ans à la bande côtière c'est de son
monde n'y avait pas de présence et a pas
d'énergie marignane et pas d'acteurs qui
avait que lui était en mer il s'était
approprié tout cet espace
aujourd'hui faut faire preuve de de
commandes de bonne intelligence
parce que chaque état il est à partager
avec tout le monde au final l'impact de
turbines sur le ligne marin devrait être
assez limité projetté marins de commerce
et dont j'ai navigué sur des gros
bateaux où il y avait des hélices de 16
18 mètres qui tourne à 80 à 60 70 80
minutes et qui ont sûrement un impact
autres à mettre du fond sur la rade du
havre par exemple que des hélices de 16
mètres de diamètre qui vont tourner
entre six et huit minutes produire à
quelques kilomètres des côtes bretonnes
revient à raccourcir le circuit de
distribution du courant électrique
pour le maire de paimpol cette proximité
permet d'éviter les coupures de courant
lors des grands pics de consommation
l'impact est forcément moins important
de produire de l'énergie à proximité des
territoires que de devoir faire venir de
l'énergie nucléaire d'une centrale qui a
plus de 300 km or c'est bien le problème
de la bretagne c'est le niveau de
dépendance énergétique
on est à 91% dépendant de l'extérieur de
la région forcément le fait de venir
produire dans des sites de proximité
permettra d'éviter cet écueil da la
ferme hydrolienne de paimpol devraient
être raccordés au réseau d'ici juillet
les quatre turbines fournir ou de
l'énergie pour environ deux mille foyers
c'est à dire moins que la population de
la commune pas de quoi concurrencer l
avenir les autres sources d'énergie
et voilà pour ce reportage à paimpol
signé par pierre achkar entre temps nous
a rejoint sur ce plateau michèle rivasi
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes députée
européenne membre du groupe des verts
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire en fait ce
champ d'hydroliennes au large de paimpol
pour l'instant c'est un test on sait que
c'est une technologie qui coûte cher est
ce que c'est une technologie d'avenir
situe vraiment ce sont des technologies
d'avenir tout ce qui touche l'énergie
marine alors là on n'a vu l'usiné
marémotrice
là on voit les hydroliennes qui a un
intérêt je trouve très important parce
que le courant marin et continue voyez
par rapport à des énergies alternatives
par rapport à des éoliennes en même
temps la france est assez
un peu à l'avant garde là dessus vous
avez vu qu'edf installe quatre éoliennes
je pense que c'est 2013 2014
il ya un plan de faire des fermes
carrément d'hydroliennes et en plus
c'est à proximité voiliers de la demande
par rapport aux villes donc c'est très
prometteur et même si c'est cher à
l'heure actuelle est bien plus on va
multiplier simple on pourra le
développer plus le prix va baisser
regardez le photovoltaïque au début il
était très cher puis maintenant il est
tout à fait abordable et on va arriver à
un moment où tout ce qui est énergie
alternative sera beaucoup moins cher
qu'une énergie nucléaire qu'on est
obligé de centraliser avec tout le
problème du transport de l'électricité
donc pour moi c'est il faut vraiment
mettre le paquet sur ces énergies
marines et quand j'ai regardé la carte
européenne
eh bien la france et l'angleterre c'est
là où il ya le potentiel sur justement
les énergies hydroliennes par rapport au
courant qu'ils sont le plus développées
de l'europe donc allons-y
alors on va parler la sortie potentielle
du nucléaire on y voit ce que ça coûte
mais est-ce qu'on a les moyens en temps
de crise économique telle qu'on la
connaît aujourd'hui d'investir sur ce
type d'énergie sachant ce que ça coûte
et bien si vous voulez le problème du
coup il faut regarder au problème de
l'emploi par exemple au niveau d'une
forme de chair mille emplois créés
exactement et ses 10000 emplois créés
sont beaucoup plus importants que les
emplois qu'on peut créer dans le cas du
nucléaire
donc s'il ya de l'argent à investir
parce que là on est dans
l'investissement
voyez à court moyen et long terme cet
investissement sur les énergies
alternatives produisent beaucoup plus
d'emplois que par rapport au nucléaire
donc et au niveau du coup on pourra
après exporté si la france devient
leader voyez sur alors on a parlé des
hydroliennes mais il ya aussi on peut
produire d'électricité par rapport aux
vagues on peut produire de l'ex-société
même par rapport à une différence de
salinité différence de température donc
il ya un potentiel de technologies qui
peuvent permettre de fournir de
l'énergie notamment au niveau de la
proximité et pas comme l'ancien modèle
qu'on avait c'est un modèle hyper
centralisé alors justement il ya un des
intervenants de ce reportage qui se
faisait un petit commentaire concernant
la capacité de production de ces
machines
on les écoute
il nous paraît assez vraisemblable que
il y aura demain des ferme hydrolienne
de quelle puissance et au total combien
la france disposera-t-elle de mégawatts
installés on y revient c'est impossible
à dire aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on connaît ce chiffre michèle
rivasi est ce qu on sait combien on peut
produire avec des hydroliennes bah
écoutez les évaluations café dfc autour
de 3 gigawatts ça veut dire à peu près
trois réacteurs nucléaires mais il ya
d'autres sources d'énergie potentielle
s'est par exemple de l'énergie fournie
par rapport aux vagues
on peut aussi fabriquer d'électricité
par rapport des différences de
température ou même de salinité
donc il ya un potentiel énorme et puis
il faut plus raisonner monoculture royer
sur la fabrication d'électricité
il faut raisonner plutôt territoire
c'est à dire regardez tout ce qui est
bretagne où justement il ya un manque
d'électricité
on sait que tous les ans effectivement
il ya des il ya des preuves de
rationnement parce qu'il manque délecte
louis puis surtout il sait la très froid
où il ya des pointes
il ya un an donc si on multiplie voyait
les sources de fabrication d'électricité
en tenons compte des atouts de chaque
région et en même temps en jouant sur la
diminution de la consommation d'énergie
avec des appareils voiliers qui demande
moins d'énergie moins d'électricité qu'à
l'heure actuelle et bien on peut très
bien rentrés dans le cadre de la
diminution du nucléaire au profit de la
multiplication des énergies
renouvelables alors il ya un autre
problème c'est que selon un rapport de
rte donc le réseau de transport
d'électricité on risque d'assister en
fait à des tensions sur le réseau
électrique dès 2016
il va manquer donc en 2016 1,2 gigawatts
et en 2017 2,1 notamment semble-t-il à
cause de l'arrêt de fessenheim est ce
qu'on a vraiment les moyens de sortir du
nucléaire aujourd'hui à bien écouter ça
c'est les chiffres que je voudrais voir
de plus près parce que et erronée mois
d'octobre oui s'ils voulaient le gros
souci qu'on a en france c'est lors des
pointes lorsqu'il fait très froid
puisque l'énergie nucléaire civile et la
centrale on peut pas là réajusté en
fonction de la demande donc la première
des choses que fait le gouvernent
c'est de dire il faut isoler les
bâtiments pour qu'ils aient moins de
demandes sur l'électricité notamment le
chauffage électrique
bon en même temps il faut avoir des
appareils qui demandent moins
d'électricité c'est tout ce qu'on
appelle la diminution de la consommation
la demande d'électricité
et puis ensuite il faut diversifier on a
quelques années pour énormément
développer les énergies renouvelables
voyez le photovoltaïque il faut que au
niveau des toits au niveau des grandes
surfaces on puisse développer soulevé
cette énergie solaire pourtant regardez
le photovoltaïque on a un petit peu
planté je dirais la filière l'éolien on
a présenté l'affilié le gouvernement
succès tel manque de moyens certainement
ou peut-être un manque de volonté
politique je vous voyais la question
mais on a vu que donc l'éolien aussi
n'est pas aussi développés qu'ils
auraient dû selon ce qui avait été prévu
en 2007 lors du grenelle de
l'environnement
comment vous expliquez est ce que c'est
un manque de volonté politique qu'est ce
qui se passe alors à mon avis et on l'a
vu sur le grenelle et c'est vraiment un
manque de volonté politique parce que à
la banque de finance aussi peut-être
mais le manque de finances vous pouvez
toujours investir on peut toujours faire
des emprunts dans le cadre de
l'investissement saoulé par rapport à la
demande
or on l'a vu sur le photovoltaïque
lorsque on a fait ce moratoire ça a
cassé complètement le développement
moi dans ma région dans la drôme il y
avait plus de 1000 emplois créés voyez
sur l'installation des cellules toutes
les entreprises ont fermé
alors après on me dit mais le prix de
rachat était trop trop élevé mais les
industriels étaient prêts à diminuer le
prix donc il ya eu un manque de volonté
sur l'éolien nous regarder par rapport à
l'allemagne mais il ya c'est un abîme de
différence et allemagne revient en
charbon elle sort de
l'électricité nucléaire pour revenir
voter d'abord elles construisent de
nouvelles centrales au charbon qui
émettent beaucoup moins de co2 et
surtout elles font la transition par
rapport au gaz mais vous voyez que
pendant quelques années on est à 30 %
d'énergie renouvelable
donc nous moi je pense à quoi je pense à
l'emploi pour l'emploi il faut
développer voyeur on a parlé des
hydroliennes tout à l'heure c'est une
source d'emplois incroyable on va faire
de l'éolien offshore
l'éolien offshore c'est plus de 15000
emplois dans toute la région c'est là où
il ya ce potentiel s'est pas encore dans
les vieilles énergie obsolète et qui
nous pose problème si jamais il ya un
accident nucléaire
donc moi je demande de l'audace il faut
de l'audace il faut de l'investissement
mais voyait productif et puis par
rapport à la demande des gens il faut
d'abord une formation professionnelle et
puis il faut absolument développer des
nouvelles énergies qui empruntent
beaucoup moins de risques bah écoutez
merci michel rivasi on suivra
effectivement le développement ou pas de
cette nouvelle énergie nous c'est la fin
de cette émission on se retrouve dans 15
jours cette fois ci à bruxelles bonne
suite de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires